let omega be a complex cube root of
unity with omega not being equal to one
a fair die is thrown three times if r1
r2 and r3 are the numbers obtained on
the die then the probability that omega
to the r1 plus omega to the r2 plus
omega to the r3 equals 0 is
it's a fascinating problem so let's just
start with the first part and then see
if some patterns fall into place for us
to be able to tackle the second second
part so omega is a complex cube root of
unity which is just a fancy way of
saying it's a complex cube root of one
with omega not being equal to one so
let's just set up let's just set up an
equation here let's try to think about
all of the cube roots let's just think
about all of the cube roots of one so if
we say that's an analogous to figuring
out all of the x's that satisfy x to the
third is equal to 1. or we can subtract
1 from both sides of this equation and
write this as x to the third minus 1 is
equal to 0. all of all of the roots of
this equation right here will be cube
roots of 1. they will satisfy this over
here this is the same thing as this is
the same thing as i could write over
here x is equal to the cube root
is equal to the cube root of one these
are all equivalent statements so how do
we do that
well we know what one of the roots are
we know that x equals we know that x
equals one is
is
is a root or another way we can think
about it we know that x minus 1 is a
factor here we know that this can be
factored as x minus 1 times something
something something squared plus
something x some quadratic some let me
write here some second
some quadratic
some quadratic right here is equal to
zero we can factor this and to figure
out what the quadratic is we just have
to do a little bit of polynomial i guess
we could call it algebraic long division
we just have to divide x minus 1 into
this and then we'll get what this
quadratic is so let's do that
let us divide
x minus 1
x minus 1 into
into
x to the third minus 1. and i'll i'll do
it in place so this is the third degree
place x to the third i'll leave space
for x for the x squared place leave
space for the x to the first place and
then we have x to the 0 which is the
ones place so that's negative 1. so i
just wrote x to the third minus 1 but i
wrote it out this will have a space to
kind of keep our counting pretty clean
so we just do algebraic long division
here
so x minus 1 goes into x to the third
minus one you just look at the highest
degree terms x goes into x to the third
x squared times
it goes x squared times x squared times
x is x to the third x squared times
negative one is minus
x squared now we want to subtract the
magenta stuff from the orange stuff or
we could add the negative of it so let's
just multiply this times negative 1. so
positive
sorry multiplying it times negative 1 so
this is a negative and then this will
become a positive we're subtracting what
i originally had written from that but i
just made it negative and now we'll add
and so this will become
these cancel out we get x squared
minus
x squared
minus one just algebraic long division
once again how many times does x minus 1
go into x squared minus 1. look at the
highest degree terms x goes into x
squared i'll just arbitrarily switch
colors x goes into x squared x times so
this is plus
x
x times x is x squared x times negative
1 is negative x
same drill subtract this from up there
or we could add the negative so this
becomes negative this becomes positive
these guys cancel out you get x
bring this down x minus one
x minus one goes into x minus one
exactly one time
it goes exactly one time one times x
minus one is x minus 1 and you get a
remainder 0. so it divided evenly which
makes sense because this is one of the
factors of that we know that this is a
root so if we wanted to factor
if we want to completely factor this we
can write this as
x minus one
times
this thing over here times a quadratic
times
x squared plus x plus one is equal to
zero
so if we wanted to find the non-one
roots
of this over here we just have to find
the roots of this thing right over here
whatever the roots are this we're going
to make this expression equal to 0 which
would make this entire expression equal
to 0 make this entire expression equal
to 0. so we just have to find this guy's
roots and i could already guess that
they're going to be complex so you know
don't even attempt to factor it you
could attempt to factor it if you like
just by looking at it but we're going to
use the quadratic formula so the roots
here
the roots for this part we say x is
equal to negative b b is one so negative
one
plus or minus the square root
of b squared b is one so one
minus four
minus four times a times c well a and c
are both one so it's just minus four
all of that
all of that over two times a a is just
one so all of that over two so x is
equal to
negative one plus or minus the square
root the square root of negative three
and we were right this is going to be a
complex root over
over two now what's the square root of
negative three we could write this we
could write this square root of negative
three this is the same thing as the
square root of negative 1 times the
square root of 3 and this we know from
studying imaginary numbers and complex
numbers this is the this is i
that right there is i so the other roots
and there are 2 here because we're plus
plus square root of negative 3 and
subtracting the square root of negative
3. so the other roots are x could be
equal to negative 1
plus or minus the square root of 3
square root of 3 times i and i'll put i
here just we it's nice and clear that's
that not that's not a vector just just
like that i
all of that
all of that over
2. so what we just did so far is we were
able we now know all three
all three
roots of one especially if we're
thinking about the complex roots one is
one of the roots the other roots are
negative one plus the square root of 3 i
over 2 and negative 1 minus the square
root of 3 i over 2. and so they're
saying that omega is one of these two
roots we either take the positive or the
negative and it looks like it doesn't
matter it says let omega be a complex
cube root of unity so it could be one
either one of these so let's just pick
one of them
so let's just make
let's just
let's just say omega is equal to omega
is equal to negative one
minus
the square root of 3 i
minus the square root of 3i and i'll
just distribute the divided by 2. so we
could say we could call this let me
write it this way
it's negative one-half
minus the square root of 3 over 2
i i'm just picking once again not a
vector my brain keeps wanting to put a
little hat on top of it it's not a
vector it's just an imaginary number
it's i well this is actually a complex
number because we have a real part and
an imaginary part so i'm just going to
pick that to be to be my omega it's one
of the non-one complex roots
third roots or i guess we could say what
was the actual wording they said one of
the cube roots one of the complex cube
roots of one of unity that is not one so
let's just let omega be equal to that
so this first statement can translate
into this and then a fair die is thrown
three times if r1 r2 r3 are the numbers
obtained on the die then the probability
that omega to the r so let's think about
this a little bit let's think about the
because we're going to be taking omega
to different powers
so let's think about what happens when
we take this omega to different powers
so this is clearly
this right here is clearly omega to the
first power the way we've defined it
let's think about what omega squared is
so omega squared is equal to
negative one half
minus square root of three over two i
and this will give us good practice
multiplying complex numbers times
negative one-half minus times this was
the same thing we're squaring it
and so this is going to be equal to
negative one-half times negative
one-half is
positive one-fourth and then you have
negative one half times negative three
halves i the negatives cancel out
or the square root of three halves i
should say so negative one half times
this is going to be positive square root
of 3 over
4
over 4 i
then we can multiply this times this
it's going to give us the same thing as
that so
the negatives cancel out and so we have
plus
square root of 3 over 4 i
and then we're going to want to multiply
and then we're going to want to multiply
the two the two imaginary terms so the
negatives cancel out and so you have
square root of 3 times square root of 3
which is just 3
and then you have 2 times 2 which is 4
and then you have i times i which is
negative 1. so let me just put a
negative 1 so times negative 1 over here
so let's simplify this
this gives us 1 4
1 4
plus
square root of 3 over 4 i plus square
root of 3 over 4 i that's 2 square roots
of 3 over 4 i or square root of so
that's the same thing as square root of
3 over two
i
and then minus three fourths minus
three fourths and we can simplify this
even more the real parts we can add
one-fourth minus three-fourths is
negative two-fourths or negative
one-half this is negative
negative one-half plus
square root of three
over two i so that's interesting when i
squared omega i got another one of the
another one of the cube roots complex
cube roots of one actually got its
conjugate and if any of y'all who've
studied complex analysis and think about
the complex plane it should be pretty
clear why this happened but if you don't
don't worry too much about it now what i
want to do is i want to i want to i want
to i want to take omega to the third
power just to really understand what's
happening what's happening with omega
and if you studied complex analysis this
part would be quicker for you you would
you would know it so what's omega to the
third power omega third power is going
to be omega squared times omega omega
squared is just that right over there we
just calculated it it's negative one
half plus
square root over square root of three
over two
i
and we have to multiply that times omega
omega was the conjugate of this thing so
it's negative one half minus conjugate
just means opposite sign on the complex
part so minus square root of three over
two i
that's what we defined omega to be right
over here this right here over here is
omega that's omega this right here is
omega squared so let's multiply these
so first
negative one-half times negative
one-half gives us negative
negative sorry it gives us positive one
fourth have to be careful this gives us
one-fourth
and then
if we take if we take negative one-half
negative one-half i shouldn't do it that
way let's do negative one-half times
negative square root of three over two i
negatives cancel out so we get plus
square root of 3
let me make sure i have square root of 3
over 4
i
and then we can multiply this times this
it gives us the same thing so it gives
us plus
plus let me make sure i'm doing this
right oh no it's not going to give us
the same thing now 1 is negative 1 is
positive so it's going to give us
be very careful so negative 1 half times
positive square root of three over two i
is
negative square root of three
over four
i
and then finally multiply the two
imaginary parts multiply that i don't
wanna use it i wanna use a different
color multiply that times that
that gives us positive times a negative
gives us a negative square root of 3
times square root of 3 is 3.
2 times 2 is 4
i times i is negative 1
or we can multiply the negative one
times this negative over here becomes a
positive so what do we get
these guys cancel out we have one-fourth
plus three-fourths it is equal to
one
it is equal to one so this is
interesting this is interesting over
here so omega omega is equal to this
thing right over here
omega squared is equal to its conjugate
omega squared is equal to its conjugate
right over here we just swap the sine
over there and then omega to the third
is going to be equal to this thing is it
going to be equal to unity actually we
knew that we i i shouldn't even have to
worry about this i don't know i even
went through that process well it was
good multiplying we knew it was the cube
root of unity so we knew if we took it
to the third power so this was to some
degree just a waste of time but what
does this tell us so we now kind of
understand what the different powers of
omega what will omega to the fourth
power be
what's going to be this times omega so
it's just going to be omega again what's
omega to the fifth power it's going to
be this what's omega to the sixth power
it's going to be this again so let's
just use that and we're going to tackle
that in the next part of the problem in
the next video